[Music]
great okay welcome everyone to the
afternoon session and we have three
great speakers this afternoon and i'd
like to start with
aroki chen from university of washington
she's going to be speaking about some
joint work with ian tatley and kevin
tian
go ahead
okay um so thank you for the
introduction thank you for coming uh to
my talk uh so i'll present our work uh
structured log concave sampling with a
restricted gaussian article and this is
a joint work with impali from udab and
msr and kevin pm from stanford
so in this talk i will first introduce
some basics of log concave sampling
and and give an overview of our results
i'll then talk about
proximal reduction framework a very
useful tool we developed
that can reduce the query complexity of
a large class of samplers
i will also talk about how we can
build samplers for two structured log
concave distributions the finite sum
distribution and the composite
distribution and how we can apply this
proximal reduction framework to reduce
the query complexity of those two
samplers
let's start from the with the
introduction
so in this talk we will focus on
sampling from log concave distributions
we say a distribution is not concave
if for some convex function f we can
write the density function of the
distribution in the form of
e2 minus
f um the goal of our work is to design
some efficient algorithms that can
sample from some
target log concave distribution pi star
uh in a typical setting we don't know
the closed form of the function f or the
normalization constant
but we assume we have access to a zero
or first order oracle um so given some
query x
the oracle can return the function value
f x or the gradient value graph f x
we also assume that the function f is mu
strongly convex and l smooth we let the
condition number on kapha be l over mu
so this is the typical setting um
settings we study uh a variance of this
typical setting
so the reason is in practice the
function f
can have some special structures so
designing our samplers based on their
special structures can be more efficient
than if we um use a single
general purpose sampler to sample all
distributions and in our work we studied
two structures
one is the final sum structure and the
other one is the composite structure
for the finite sum structure
we have some distribution in the form of
e2 minus f and here this f can be
written as the sum of some small f i's
we assume that each of i is l smooth we
also assume that the sum f is strongly
convex
we assume we have access to a gradient
or value article grad f i or f i um so
here for this article instead of
returning the
gradient or the function value of the
whole function it only returns
the gradient value of a function value
of some f i for some i
so in this case if we want to compute
the gradient or or the function value of
the whole function
it can take n curves
and that that's expensive so we don't
want to create too many
uh too many samples in each iteration
example of such distribution is the
posterior distribution so for posterior
distribution
we have some data set z and some
parameter data the posterior
distribution of the
parameter given the data set
can be written in the form of
e2 minus log p theta
minus the sum of some terms that depend
on the samples
so in practice
the data set can have
a lot of samples so we don't want to
create too many samples in one iteration
for the composite distribution
we have some
we have some
target distribution in the form of e2
minus f
minus g um so there are two parts the uh
the first part is the f part which is a
real condition function with condition
number kappa uh the g part uh is so this
the function g is convex
but possibly not real conditions
and in this case for the wheel condition
part f
we assume we have access to a value of
gradient oracle f x or greater f x
for the g parts
we assume g of means or rgo which means
for some fixed lambda and v
for all fixed lambda and v we can sample
from
density in the form of
e2 minus one over lambda x minus v
squared minus g
so this is saying that if we can build
an efficient sampler for
this distribution
then even when the function g is not
real conditioned uh if it has a rgo that
has a closed form solution or is
computable in od
we can still build an efficient sampler
for this type of distribution and this
covers the case when g has a
simple
when g is simple and easy to sample from
an example of such
distribution is when g is the indicator
of some of a box
in this case
even though g is not well conditioned
it can still be easy to sample from
another example is when g is coordinate
separable
like in the case of l y regularization
in this case
what we need to do is we on uh what we
need to do to sample this rgo is to
sample
d many one-dimensional distributions so
in this case it can also be easy to
sample from
its rgo
so in our project we studied the
query complexity to get a sample from
some distribution pi hat that is
absolutely close to the target
distribution pi star our results are in
tv distance
and we care about the current complexity
as a function of the number of samples n
the dimension d the condition number
kappa and the inverse of the target
accuracy one over epsilon
so we build high accuracy samplers uh
for for the finite sum distribution and
the composite distribution
here high accuracy means we can uh the
samplers can achieve epsilon error in
polylog bang over epsilon queries and
this is in general harder than if we
only want a poly one over epsilon
dependence uh the reason is if if we
want to get some
high accuracy sampler we need to make
sure the bias of the samplers
stays stay very low throughout the
algorithm
also i like to mention that
for our algorithms we are starting from
feedable starts which means that
the starting distribution of our
algorithms are exponential warm starts
okay um so in optimization uh for both
the finite sum this uh finite sum
function and the composite function uh
there are efficient algorithms to
optimize them but in sampling
especially in the high accuracy regime
we don't know much
to mention some related works
so for the finance some distribution
a lot of works
have studied the low accuracy regime
which means uh the regime with uh poly
one over epsilon dependence
but for the high accuracy regime uh we
don't know any uh samplers better than
the general purpose sampler so in this
case for the finite sum distribution if
we use a general purpose sampler to
sample from it
it can take n times kappa d
queries which is very expensive when the
number of samples n is large
for the composite distribution
there are also some work studying the
low accuracy regime for the high
accuracy regime
more at all 2019
give an algorithm with polycarpathy
career complexity
but they require many additional
assumptions
including access to normalization factor
of the rgo
liciousness of g and some others
so for the case we study uh we don't
know any better samplers for for better
samplers than the general
sampler either and in this case if we
use the general purpose sampler it can
take d cube query complexity
so in our work we
build some
built high accuracy samplers
for both the finite sum distribution and
the composite distribution
another
contribution of our work is we
develop a proximal reduction framework
which is a reduction framework that can
improve current complexity depend
dependence on kappa from polynomial or
even exponential um to linear
so for example if we have some sampler
on some target distribution pi star
with kappa q100d
current complexity
like with very bad dependence on the
condition number kappa
our reduction framework can bootstrap
the sampler to a carpet decor complexity
sampler
and in this case it's linear in paper
so so we use this proximal reduction
framework to bootstrap our samplers for
for the composite distribution and the
finance distribution together to get
some samplers with linear dependence on
the condition number kappa
also
we believe this
reduction framework
maybe of independent interest and can
have
other applications as well
so in our work we first
give
some high accuracy samplers
with polycarp dependence
for the finite sum distribution the
composite distribution and then using
our proximal reduction framework uh we
are able to reduce
uh the career complexity to lingering
papa
so here we show the final query
complexity results
okay so this is an overview of our
results
next i will talk
in details how we can build this
proximal reduction framework to reduce
the query complexity of
a large class of samplers
um so our proximal reduction framework
is based on a concept called rgo
restricted gaussian oracle
um so instead of sampling directly from
our target distribution
what what we do is we consider an
intermediate step um to sample from some
distribution in the form of
e2 minus one over lambda
x minus v squared minus f
for some lambda and b
so this mirrors the use of proximal
oracle in optimization
what it does is
it adds a quadratic term to the original
function to make the function more
real conditioned and easier to sample
from
so here by choosing a small lambda
the sum of f x and the quadratic term
can be more well conditioned than the
original function f x
so for example if we have some function
f
which is mu strongly convex and l smooth
and we choose lambda to be roughly 1
over l
then the condition number of
this sum f x and the quadratic term will
be a constant
um so in this way we reduce the
condition number from kappa to a
constant
and using this property of rgo
we are able to get a reduction framework
that improves query complexity
dependence on kappa from polynomial to
linear
so with with this rgo
next i'll show how we can build up build
our proximal reduction framework
so now suppose our goal is just to
sample
from some general distribution
pi star
instead of sampling directly from it we
can consider a joint distribution on x
and y in the form of e2 minus fx
minus one over two eta x minus y y
squared so this
distribution pi hat is a joint
distribution of x and y
uh the interesting thing about this
joint distribution is um if we look at
the the x margin of this distribution
it's exactly pi star the the target
distribution we want so if we want to
sample from our target distribution pi
star it is enough to sample from this
joint distribution pi head x y and take
and then take the x marginal
and to sample from this joint
distribution uh we use an alternate
sampling loop
so we uh so in our algorithm we
repeatedly doing the following two steps
uh in the first step we conditional on
some um so conditional on some x we
sample from
the sample from y and in the second step
conditional on some y we sample from x
so we can prove that this alternate
sampling loop converges exactly to the
joint distribution pi head the
distribution we want we can also prove
that um we are able
so this algorithm
can sample from pa hat in one over eta
mu iterations
so here the intuition of this one over
eta is uh we can view this eta as a step
size so for example if we look at the
first step the y step
so imagine if uh imagine we have some
small eta
then the distribution of y will be very
concentrated around x
then we cannot move far
from x in one step and if uh and and if
the order uh and if it's hard for the
algorithm to travel much in one step of
iteration uh the algorithm needs to take
many steps for it to converge
so um so the mixing time is about one
over eta mu
uh for this alternate sampling loop the
first step is an easy step because it is
just the gaussian distribution
uh for the second step um so if there is
some sampler on x
from
from e to minus f that takes
polycarbonate um queries
um then we can here we can choose eta to
be roughly one over l and then using the
exact same sampler to sample from x uh
from the e to minus f minus this
quadratic term
uh can only take
uh
of d
which is independent of the condition
number kappa
so we can show this second step only
take
od no matter what the condition number
of the function f is
then the total current complexity of
this algorithm is
d
the curse it needs in one iteration over
eta
the number of iterations we need which
is kappa
in kappa
so in this way we improve the dependence
on kappa from polynomial to linear
method
yeah yeah it just mirrors the that
concept in optimization
uh so to summarize the key idea of this
proximal reduction framework what we do
here is um by adding a quadratic term to
the function or adding a thousand
distribution if you think of it as a
distribution
we make the function more real
conditioned and easier to sample from
and by
control
by using an alternate sampling loop we
make sure that the x
x marginal of the distribution always
stays correct
uh what distance
is in tv distance
yeah yeah so
so for the second step uh we
uh so a typical sampler is like uh for
example for mala we can
it has like guarantee in tv distance and
then you can just plug in that sampler
to the second step
uh i think it needs to be epsilon
the final target accuracy
uh yeah so if you want the absolute
accuracy to to sample from the joint
distribution you want the epsilon
um
sampler for the second step
a quick comment so the second uh the
second step you can imagine every time
it fails
you can just couple that entire failure
probability over the entire algorithm
so the second step if you run for n
iterations and you set the second
tolerance like epsilon over two n
then the total accumulated error is like
epsilon over two
so it can tolerate that kind of thing
[Music]
any other questions
[Music]
so for the alter when you do the
alternating something yeah you assume
your f is neutronic convex
right
yes can you do something for just convex
do you have a
outer complexity for just convex f
uh so if the function f is um
so the reason we need uh we
the reason we need this strongly
convexity is because uh when proving the
convergence rate we need that for the
iso perimetry
um so here for new strongly convex we we
have this uh mu
uh
um mu
this mu bond on the isoparametry but if
you use some other assumption and you
can still get that as a perimeter you
can still prove some similar results
another question is
the rgo is like a
some
analog of a
proximal operator in optimization
and for optimization for this outer
analysis you can do acceleration to
improve the complexity bound to
from one or at a mu to one or square
root of phytomu
is this possible in sampling to improve
the outer bond
so are you asking if it's possible to
improve
the one over atom here to one over
square root of mu yes um
not sure about it
um
yeah i'm not sure about if it's possible
but
so you think uh but using the algorithm
we show here the bond we get is one over
800.
okay thank you
[Music]
okay so this is the proximal reduction
framework
next i'll show
how we can build high accuracy samplers
for
two structured log concave distributions
the finite sum distribution the
composite distribution
so let's start from the finite sum
distribution
uh so before going into the finite sum
distribution i want to first talk about
how we can build a high accuracy sampler
uh for the
for some general log concave
distribution so we can better understand
the difficulty in building a high
accuracy sampler for the finite sum
distribution so now suppose our goal is
just to
sample from some log concave target
distribution
pi star
and here the
function f is real conditioned
um so a common method people use is uh
we first find the markov process with
stationary distribution pi star
and then we run the discretized markov
process on until convergence
and after that process converges
we can get a point
that is close to the station and
distribution pi star
so
so one common markov process people use
is the language dynamic
which is basically a
gradient flow combined with a brannial
motion
and to discretize this
markov process
there are many methods we can use one
common method is the euler method so for
this method if we want to simulate some
the markov process on some interval
we can use the gradient at the initial
point of that
of that interval to approximate all the
gradients on that interval uh like what
we do in gradient descent
and we can show that
this type of algorithm um like grounding
some discretized markov process will
have a clear complexity with polynomial
dependence on one over epsilon
but in our algorithm we hope that we can
get some higher accuracy
samplers with polylog 1 over epsilon
dependence
the reason that this type of algorithm
is not is not accurate enough
is when we discretize the continuous
process
we change the we change the stationary
distribution of it so we can take some
small step adap to make sure that the
discretization error is not too large
but once we disclose it
it cannot it can never converge to the
correct distribution
so the this
accuracy issue what we can do is we can
apply a metropolis hosting filter to
adjust the stationary distribution
so here i show
one of the most popular metropolis
adjusted algorithms
metropolis adjusted language algorithm
mala
in mala
we repeatedly doing the following two
steps in the first step we run some
discretized version
of the lantern dynamic
and in the second step we apply some
metropolis hosting filter
so with
with some probability we accept the
points from the
from the first point
from the first
step and and
otherwise we reject that point and don't
move
so the accept probability we use is this
which is uh the minimum over one and pi
star y pi star is our target
distribution uh the probability from
of going from y to x in this first step
over pi star x times the probability of
going from x to y in this first step
we can show that
using this
using this accept probability detailed
balance is satisfied
and in this case for an irreducible
markov chain with detailed balance there
exists a unique stationary distribution
and for for this accept
for this accept
probability the
stationary distribution is exactly pi
star
um so we can show that mala has the
stationary distribution being exactly pi
star the target distribution and using
this property
we can show that molar is a high
accuracy sampler with log one over
epsilon dependence
so now let's go back to the finite sum
distribution we have seen that mala is a
high accuracy sampler for
the general or concave distribution
so uh one naive strategy we can try is
we can run some stochastic gradient
version of mala
to get some high accuracy sampler for
the finite sum distribution what this
means is
in the first step of mala instead of
using the true gradient
we can use some stochastic approximation
of the gradient and computing that
stochastic gradient can be cheaper than
computing the true gradient
however if we use this naive strategy
there are two challenges the first
challenge is computing the accept
probability is hard
the reason is
we have seen that to compute the accept
probability we need to know the exact
probability of going from one point to
another in the first step
so if we use some stochastic gradient
here
that that probability of going from one
point to another can be uncheckable
the second challenge is
even if we know the exact probability of
going from one point to another
actually computing it can still be very
expensive so in this traditional
metropolis casting step
we need to query grad fi or fi for ri
which is very
expensive and we need to we want to
avoid doing that
uh so to overcome those two challenges
the algorithm we use is the metropolis
random work so in this algorithm
in the first step
instead of using the gradient to update
what we do is we just add a brownian
motion and forget about the gradient
so this algorithm um metropolis the
random work has a worse condition number
dependence than mala uh the reason is
um it doesn't use any gradient
information in the first step
so it's not as efficient as mala but
since we have that proximal reduction
framework which can reduce the
condition number carpal dependence um
using this metropolis random work we can
still get an efficient sampler
so in the first step we just do some
brownian motion and for the second step
in mala the accept probability
we use is this
this can take unqueries to compute
so
in our
and in our
algorithm
we use a variant of this except
probability so the accept probability we
use is
c
some constant times square root uh e2
minus the function value at the new
point uh over e2 minus the function
value at the old point
so here the constant say is making sure
the accept probability um stays below 1
with high probability
the benefit of using this new accept
probability is
we can get an unbiased estimator of this
accept probability easily and here to
to use an unbiased estimator to accept
or reject is equivalent to using the
true value
and computing the unbiased method can be
much cheaper than computing the true
value
we can also show that using this new
accept accept probability
the transition is still reversible
so this is verifying that detailed
balance is still
satisfied so our algorithm still
converges to the
exact target accuracy pi star
to get an unbiased estimator
what we need to do is at at each
iteration
we sample each eye independently with
probability p
uh we can show that it is enough to
choose this p to be roughly one over n
and then in that case we only need
constantly many queries at each at each
iteration
um so in our analysis we use that uh um
the the minimizers of all functions i's
are the same
but by adding some linear term we can
assume that without loss of generality
i'm sorry
[Music]
how large is that constancy
yeah because for one thing
oh thank you
uh yeah so for one thing uh
uh if you use that acceptance
probability it's not always guaranteed
to be same below one
and of course when your c is small it's
uh
more very likely to be below one but on
the other side if you take c small
you'll see a lot of rejections okay so
uh so the uh this c we choose here is
not exactly a
constant it depends on
the the parameters of the function so it
depends on like the
how strongly convex and like smooth this
function is
uh so i i don't remember the exact
choice of c
uh
but uh
but we showed that uh there exists some
say that by using that it's possible to
um get an algorithm like without reject
reject too often
yeah so it looks like
oh okay so it looks like you can afford
the the computation of the exact
gradient but you still need to
uh calculate the exact function value so
in other words if there are
if only is a lot you still need to
for example make one part of the the
data side so do you think
this rejection probability can be
further
relaxed to be
something
only depend on
the
sum of the subside of the
function values on the data set
so i don't think we need to compute all
the function values
because here we to compute the exact
probability what we do is we use an
unbiased estimator of it
um so okay with some probability we
sample that function
and we compute this uh if if if if that
function is sampled we need the we need
to compute it but if
if it is not sampled we just need this
value to be one so we don't need to
create any value of that i see okay
thank you for the clarification thank
you
any other questions
okay
okay so in this way by combining a
metropolis random work and i estimated
accept probability we get a
sampler with current complexity and plus
kappa squared d
and as a final step we can apply our
proximal reduction framework
um and to and reduce the current
complexity to
a linear input m plus kappa max d square
root nd
so this this gives the first
high accuracy sampler with long trivial
gradient curve complexity for the finite
sum distribution
and uh we can
so uh so also in the case when the
number of sample a is one
this result recovers uh the the best
known career complexity for the general
log concave distribution capacity
okay so this is the final sum
distribution and next i will show how we
can
um build this hierarchical system there
for the product for the composite
distribution
okay okay sure so for the composite
distribution uh the strategy we use is
we separate the sampling from the f part
and the g part
so since since the f part is real
condition we know some efficient
algorithm to sample from this part and
for the three parts since we have this
rgo it can still be easy to sample from
so what we do is we we still use some
alternate sampling loop to sample from
it
and in this case
this alternate sampling loop will
converge to a joint distribution on pi
hat but the x marginal of that joint
distribution is not exactly what we want
so we want to apply a final rejection
sampling step to adjust that
distribution
uh and and
in order for this rejection sampling
step to be successful
we don't want this
marginal distribution pi head and pi
star to be very far
and in this algorithm we have the
freedom to choose this parameter eta and
we can show that the rejection sampling
rejects with no probability
for a smaller eta um the intuition is
just for smaller eta x and y are closer
to each other because of this that
quadratic term
um but we still we don't want to choose
a data that is too small because this
algorithm converges in one of our eta
iterations
so we want to choose the largest data so
that pi star and pi hat are closed and
in our work we choose a that to be
one over kappa l d
and in this week by combining an
alternate sampling and a rejection
sampling
we get a
we get a sampler with copper scrub the
curry complexity and by applying the
proximal reduction framework we reduce
the query complexity to linear in kappa
and this gives them high accuracy
composite sampler with
better mixing time than general purpose
concave sampler
it also recovers the best known career
complexity for the
general distribution when g is zero
okay so to summarize we
show a proximal reduction framework
we also show uh how we can build
um
some two high accuracy samplers for the
finite sum distribution and the
composite distribution
um to mention some open problems
one open problem is um are there any
better samplers
than the
so so is there an uh so are there any
better samplers without the proximal
reduction framework so in our work what
we do is we first get some sub optimal
samplers and then apply the proximal
reduction framework so the so one
question we can explore is is it
possible to get some better samplers
without going through that proximal
reduction framework
and another open problem is uh what are
the lower bounds for the structured log
concave distributions so what we're
showing our work upper bounds on
sampling from them so one question we
can explore is um what are the lower
bounds look like and
and if there's any gap between the lower
bound and the upper bound
and that's all i have thank you
thank you so uh maybe just time for one
question we had lots of questions during
the talk so
i have a burning question before we take
a break
what does it say about zeroth order
sampling
um
you mean you mean we only have a
value oracle yeah what can we do in that
regime
so i think if you i think if you look at
the
uh finite sum distribution the algorithm
we use is the metropolis random work and
so and and in this case we don't really
need to know any gradient information
but but we what we lose here is just a
capacitance
and since we have that proximal
reduction framework
we can reduce that
and that uh not so good combat abundance
to a
linear income so
uh
so it's it's kind of saying that um
with that proximal reduction framework
um
a zero
oracle is enough
okay great thank you uh thank you again
rookie so let's
[Music]
thank
you minutes i guess